nobody wakes up and says I hate that
constellation over there that's a
republican constellation I will not look
at it but why has it become so
politicized it is atmospheric chemistry
which is derived physics it's actually a
wonderful science what has caused it to
come a Cropper if you like or become so
politicized is that the implications of
it uh mean that we need a radical
restructuring of the way Society Works
globally in order to reduce greenhouse
gas emissions and find other ways of
using energy many scientists in the
business have come to mix up their role
as informers and advisors with that of
persuading and trying to dictate policy
and I think scientists cross the line
when they do that